[Music]  dear mr. core three days ago my son  Bailey was taken by wolves no one in the  village will hunt them my husband will  come home from the war soon I must have  something to show him  so you come to kill it - kill the one  that took him I came to help if I can  to explain this if I can it's not the  first time people died out there  hillside this is heart with pieces of  bodies  [Music]  that's what you get when you talk to the  villagers people are dying it's real  enough leavis does it das you're the one  for my lawyer  yes he raised the dead I have no  questions were  ever seen anything like this before  behavioral terms of savaging no I'm not  talking about animals here mr. core well  if you say so windows  [Applause]  [Music]  you